we haven't done any pat robertson clips
lately pat robertson is the host of the
religious show the 700 club he's famous
go
he's famous at least to me for his list
of dozens of items that can be demonic
and have demons attached to them this
includes secondhand sweaters and Ouija
boards yoga Harry Potter books all of
that stuff can be demonically possessed
in the world of Pat Robertson and one of
his other sort of key identifying
characteristics is that Robertson is
blisteringly homophobic and against gay
rights and he had some commentary on a
recent show this is so weird
where he said that he and his movement
if you can call it that are being
dominated by homosexuals and the context
was left-wing bias and universities and
here is just the very oddly worded
analysis that Pat Robertson came up with
when you get right down to it and
Christians still are the overwhelming
majority in this country that in you
know we have given the ground to a small
minority you figure lesbians 1% of the
population homosexuals 2% of the
population that's all but statistically
all but they have dominated dominating
the the media they've dominated the the
cultural shift and they have infiltrated
the major universities it's just
unbelievable what's being done why is
everything so odd with Pat Robertson the
guy's 88 years old the show won't stop
and every bit of the vocabulary he uses
the the domination by the homosexual
community but the argument is actually
one I'm interested in I know it's just
sort of another silly crazy old Pat
Robertson clip but this is a really
interesting argument that he makes which
I want to talk about he basically is
saying how has there been so much
progress in the world of LGBT rights
despite the fact that actual members of
the LGBT community are a tiny tiny
percentage of the population and of
course there's lots of reasons why right
it's the
correct and decent thing to do there's
this thing called empathy where even if
you're not a member of the LGBTQ
community if you identify an injustice
you can say I'm going to activate and
work against that injustice merely
because it is an injustice even if it
doesn't affect me personally but Pat
Robertson seems to think that it's wrong
that so much as he says in this country
is being tailored to this tiny minority
and I thought well if you're going to
make that argument why does the NRA
get to dictate the conversation that
we're allowed to have on gun safety even
though they represent the interests of a
small portion of all gun owners who
themselves are only a portion of all of
the people in the United States and what
Pat Robertson is effectively complaining
about here is that as a society we're
going in the direction of treating LGBTQ
people like they are just normal people
which of course they are despite the
fact that most people aren't LGBT and
that is a really really difficult thing
for Pat Robertson to get his mind
wrapped around to him it might feel like
domination not to be able to for example
ban same-sex marriage or not to be
allowed to fire someone merely because
of their perceived or actual sexual
orientation which by the way you can
still do in a lot of states into the
United States and it's a major problem
we've got to continue working on we're
fighting against people in Pat Robertson
and his ilk who believe that merely not
discriminating is a form of oppression
and that's a really tough thing to
change someone's mind about in fact I
don't I don't really know how you do it
with Pat Robertson
I mean he's 88 years old you probably
can't change the guy's mind the most
effective method for younger people like
Pat Robertson to change their mind more
than likely is just personally knowing
members of the LGBT community knowing
them as people rather than as activists
on television television or as policy
positions or as someone that has what
they would see I guess as an
anti-christian point of view which I
disagree should should even be the
framing but even a lot of them are
probably beyond reach so
anyway pat robertson dominated by gays i
know it's a sort of weird way to get
into the topic but I think it's actually
an interesting one which is that it's
logical that we would defend the rights
of the minorities even if we aren't by
definition part of those groups right I
mean it's sort of the same thing like
the the 1964 Civil Rights Act it was
something that the majority participated
in even though it applied specifically
to the minority why is that so shocking
like why is it so crazy in Pat
Robertson's world view that people
outside of a group might still defend
and activate for the rights of that
group very difficult I guess for Pat
Robertson to understand but kind of
obvious for someone like me who just
seems to be able to empathize with the
positions of others today's program is
made possible in part by wink spelled wi
and see i like wine but i don't really
know how to select a bottle of wine and
that's what wink does wink makes it easy
to discover great wines that most
importantly you will like because every
month they ship you wines match to your
tastes and personalized to you now you
might be saying well hold on how do they
know what i will like very good question
you go to their website you go to try
wink comm slash Pakman and you fill out
this very short palate profile quiz they
will ask you questions such as how do
you like your coffee
do you like raspberries or blueberries
and based on the answers to those and a
few other questions you will get great
wines personalized to you and delivered
right to your door as you drink more
wine which i know many in our audience
do and you rate more bottles of wine
wink learns and you get even more
personalized delicious wines for next
time no membership fees skip any month
cancel anytime and there's a 100%
satisfaction guarantee so you will not
pay for a bottle you don't like and for
a limited time you can get 20 bucks off
when you go to try wink comm slash
Pakman that's t ry wi and see calm
forward-slash Pakman for $20 off check
it out